ادعى أليك بالدوين أنه
لم يسحب الزناد مطلقًا ، وأن ما
فعله هو أنه سحب المطرقة للخلف
ثم أطلقها ،
وشرح
ما حدث بالضبط ، وضح لي
ما يدعيه وكيف
يكون
ذلك مقبولًا ، لذا لا يمكن تصديقه على مسدس عمل واحد
عندما تسحب المطرقة للخلف
وهو عمل مقصود ، انقر فوق
انقر
فوق انقر
الآن يتم ضبط المطرقة عندما تسحب
المطرقة للخلف وتتركها كما ترون
أنا لا أحمل هذا ،
فأنت تعلم أن المطرقة لا تذهب إلى أي مكان
عندما  اضغط على المشغل
الذي سأفعله بهذا
الإصبع حتى تتمكن من رؤية ما هو عمل الدقيقة
الذي يتطلب القليل جدًا للضغط على
الزناد هناك ، لذا فإن
الخيار الأول الذي تعلم أنه ضغط على
الزناد ، لكنه كان بمثابة ضغط بسيط
أنه لم يكن يعلم أنه
كان يعلم أنه أمر بهذه الإشارة من دماغه
أو الخيار (ب) أنه يمسك المسدس مع الضغط
على الزناد الآن
على هذا المسدس ، لا يهم
الترتيب الذي ستدخله ، يمكنك إما توجيه
البندقية  و انت  يمكنك إطلاقه بواسطة الزناد
أو يمكنك الضغط على الزناد
بالمسدس ثم إطلاق المسدس وإذا قمت
بتحريره عند هذه
النقطة يسقط ويطلق المسدس
لذا إذا كان يسحب
إصبعه على الزناد الذي قد يكون لديه
يتم تفسيره على أنه مجرد استراحة على
الزناد ، ولكن بسحب واحد ملم ،
سيكون ذلك كافيًا
الآن يسحب المطرقة للخلف
ثم
يطلقها ، ولا يضطر إلى الضغط على الزناد
مرة أخرى إذا كان قد تعرض بالفعل للضغط عليها
من أجل البندقية  حريق وأعتقد
أن هذه حقًا نقطة أساسية في
هذا الأمر